payet truc monde
alors ces images des grandes villes
canadiennes
un jour on vous présentera des images de
la grande nature canadien on vous
accueille à thème thème canada nous
diffusons présentement en direct des
studios de radio canada international à
montréal il est 11h15 on voir 45 minutes
devant nous pour étudier une affaire
vraiment avec en apprendre beaucoup sur
une question qui nous affecte tous
d'accord c'est la promesse que je vous
livre en déduit la garantie vaujour
toujours une garantie sur les plus
divers et plus ou pas là exact c'est
dans la famille on est tous comme ça
alors autour de la table vraiment des
marteaux bonjour marie claude simard
bonjour et paloma la paloma martinez
toujours accusé d'avoir paloma avec nous
parce que ça se produit rarement parce
qu'elle est très occupé très en demande
par différents réseaux de très contents
ils savent nous avait demandés pour être
là aujourd'hui
les autres c'est un peu dur de corriger
s'il a alors aujourd'hui vous connaissez
la tradition personnes autour de la
table à part celui qui fit l'on connaît
le sujet vidéo cinq images pour tout le
monde y compris ceux qui nous regardent
en ce moment en direct partout à travers
la planète de ville sujet de l'émission
on regarde ça seulement cinq images ça
passe très rapidement vous créiez dès
que vous pensez être sur la piste on
peut rien vous cacher commerce
oui c'est un parti et à st oui oui on
parle très rien que l'agriculture c'est
au centre a ouais on pourrait dire
pestis et doit cesser d'accepter oui oui
et pollution de nos cours d'eau a parlé
le roundup est considéré comme éteint
j'ai lu ça quelque part comme un
pesticide en fait c'était avant tout
c'est un et c'est un herbicide voilà le
glyphosate est il dangereux placente
j'ai failli vous apportez moi à
l'émission aujourd'hui mais c'est un peu
lourd qu'on prenait 1,4 les de
glyphosate de demain saintot que j'ai
acheté l'an dernier parce que moi je
suis un fermier et puis des fois je
cultive pas grand chose des fois je les
affaires qui poussent de travers et je
les envie pas à côté du potager jamais
jamais mais le long de certains sentiers
par exemple s'accroître rapidement et
l'idée m'est venue pourquoi ne pas le
céder à la tentation et je suis allé au
magasin et c'était sous clé j'étais
surpris pourquoi sûr que le souple et
les le vendeur explique oui c'est sous
clé et que c'est encore plus grave aux
états unis le produit dix fois plus
concentrés et que quelqu'un qu'il
connaît comme ça à acheter du glyphosate
aux etats unis la ramener à ottawa a
répondu ça sur sa pelouse à 17 ans
voisin voisin appelé le ministère de
l'environnement
ils ont tous déterrer les le parterre de
l'homme en question ça je vous livre
donc l'information brute je ne sais pas
si c'est dangereux je n'ai pas de
vérification je peins spécialistes
commencent ont voté le bain c'est robert
stroud et quoi du moment - 2 mais là
c'est impossible
ah non moi j'adore il s'enlise je peux
pas compatibles salima ce que je
passerais ma ma nuit
c'est un symbole du printemps
je comprends pas ceux qui veulent tuer
sa respectives mais je veux pas insulter
personne là pour ça les félins sauvages
ouais tu embarques pour ceux qui
connaissent pas et glyphosate aucun
n'ont jamais entendu parler c'est quand
même essayer nouveau comme produit pour
combattre les qualifs inserm même les
mauvaises herbes mais pas ça dans la
cuisine c'est sur un petit reportage de
radio canada
un concentré de reportage de
radio-canada jeu vidéo numéro 2 s'il
vous plaît
ce soir des révélations troublantes sur
l'herbicide le plus utilisé dans le
monde le round up et son ingrédient
actif le befoza c'est la façon dont cinq
mille feux la fin on applique sur la
potion magique une potion magique classé
cancérigène probable est qu'ils ont
pourtant été approuvée à nouveau par
santé canada pour 15
monsanto a payé plus de 289 millions de
dollars un jardinier américain atteint
d'un cancer c'est bien sûr inédit est-ce
que je vous rires ils ont dit
probablement pas mais oui ça produit
alors voilà ça c'est pour l'information
toujours brut un jeu en valait dans les
nuances aujourd'hui comme on le fait à
travers chacune deux émissions d'abord
une petite partie plaisir particulier
voilà les questions sérieuses avant
l'examen d'accords des pourcentages way
est ce qu'on perd ou on gagne ou perde
c'est vous qui l'avez inventé le
règlement c'est mais j'oubliais on
serait tous celle avec le règlement
paloma oui on l'a fait comme ça ouais
coup perdu un point prochain jeu 30
points prochain jeu 50 points va de mal
en pire voici la question on affiche à
l'écran la régie comme d'habitude
excellent veut nous montrer ce dont il
est capable
c'est beau aller marie claude liger la
question pour nous lors de tests sur
3200 produits alimentaires l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments a
décelé la présence de la limite maximale
permise dans quel pourcentage d aliment
est bon vous avez un choix qu'elle est
ce choix 19% non à 1,3 pour sa baie 3,9
pour ça c'est 19% et des 30% donc votre
choix ccc c'est très bien marie-claude
choisir des vous allez dire d alors des
cdc cana dépassant la limite permise
mais si vous avez tiré pour répondu 30%
vous auriez raison c'est qu'on a
retrouvé sa dans 30 % des aliments des
traces mais dépassant la limite
autorisée
les autorités canadiennes ses 1,3 pour
cent mais 3 9% dans les céréales
des tests effectués il ya deux camps ça
se trouve dans les serial ça commence à
m'inquiéter
on va aller vers notre spécialiste
aujourd'hui pour établir les faits
louise vandelac professeure à l'institut
des sciences de l'environnement à
l'université du québec à montréal
bonjour madame van laack madame bord de
lac c'est donc une question qui me
préoccupent personnellement j'ai donc
écouté beaucoup de choses qui ont été
produits par radio canada depuis
quelques années et je suis tombé sur
vous une seule fois et en vous écoutant
j'ai trouvé que vous aviez vraiment des
connaissances étonnante sur sur ce
qu'est ce produit chimique ou d'où vient
votre intérêt
en plus de votre spécialité bien sûr
mais d'où vient votre intérêt
précisément dans ce dossier ben je
travaille beaucoup sur les questions de
santé environnementale et ces questions
de santé environnementale m'ont amené
aussi à travailler beaucoup sur
l'évolution des technosciences si on a
fait un film en 99 sur les ogm
pour l'office national du film du canada
et ça m'a amené commence à collaborer
avec bon nombre de chercheurs européens
et ses chercheurs européens ont été
parmi les premiers à travailler sur les
impacts négligé des pesticides
entre autres parce que certains d'entre
eux étaient dans les organismes
d'évaluation public et se rendait compte
que le travail était peut-être pas fait
avec tout le sérieux du ray dû être fait
donc ce sont des gens qui se sont mis à
a commencé à regarder attentivement la
façon dont c'est évalué et regarder
aussi par des études indépendantes ce
qui se passe du côté de ces herbicides
alors évidemment ça va amener depuis
déjà une dizaine d'années à siéger sur
un certain nombre d'instances à regarder
très attentivement tout ce qui se
passait puis c'est un regard
effectivement assez large
actuellement avec une équipe d'une
vingtaine de chercheurs venant de tous
les horizons c'est à dire des agronomes
des médecins
des gens qui travaillent en agronomie
mais aussi en toxicologie en
écotoxicologie ce qui permet d'avoir un
regard un peu globale sur l'ensemble des
enjeux c'est à dire à la fois les
politiques publiques à la fois les
impacts sur la santé et sur
l'environnement
bravo merci d'avoir mis la table pour
nous maintenant vous avez parlé des
agences qui s'intéresse à sa
officiellement les agences publiques y
en a une au canada qui est en train je
pense de réviser ce pas son point de vue
mais son opinion c'est parce qu on est
en train de nous dire mais peut-être
qu'on n'a pas évolué les choses
correctement qu'est-ce qui se passe
malheureusement je dois vous contredire
d'entrée parce que oui préface ah ouais
pourrait aurait dû l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments qui était
responsable de l'évaluation des obsèques
à base de glyphosate a décidé il ya
quelques années en 2017
deux rivales de ré homologué pour 15
les herbicides à base de glyphosate or
il l'a fait non pas sur la base d'une
revue scientifique en ce qu on appelle
ça young boys donc d'une revue
scientifique indépendante mais il l'a
fait essentiellement sur la base des
documents de l'industrie or ces
documents étaient pour l'essentiel très
datées on a fait un avis d'opposition là
tu donnes tout le détail montrant que
c'était moi d'amour sort de la
littérature récente qu'elle a été prise
en compte
ce qui à notre avis est absolument pas
sérieux et c'est tellement pas sérieux
que ils ont émis cet avis deux ans après
l'organisation mondiale c'est-à-dire le
seuil rc1 qui est le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
qui a établi que c'était un père un
cancérigène probable est que c'était
aussi génotoxique et ils ont fait
l'analyse non seulement sur le
glyphosate comme tel mais sur les
herbicides à base de glyphosate parce
que ça c'est un élément premier qu'il
faut comprendre
le glyphosate est supposé être le
principe actif des herbicides à base de
glyphosate mais y'a aucun agriculteur
qui va répandre dans son champ seulement
du glyphosate
donc ils répondent des herbicides à base
de glyphosate alors il faut comprendre
de quoi on parle ici ce sont des
herbicides qui contiennent un créateur
donc c'était pour nettoyer les cuves
industriels à l'origine ce qu'est la
theurre est suspecté actuellement
d'entraîner des problèmes très sérieux
de des troubles rénaux mortels il ya
plusieurs pays qui ont souffert
grandement de ses problèmes notamment le
sri-lanka ya actuellement des
interdictions de glyphosate dans
certains pays le dernier en date c'est
hier le vietnam
donc ce caractère quel acteur n'est pas
sans conséquence dans certaines régions
du monde et ça c'est un enjeu important
le fait que ce soit un cancérogène
probable
actuellement il ya onze mille deux cents
personnes souffrant d'un cancer non
hodgkinien aux états unis qui sont en
procès alors ça veut pas dire qu'il ya
seulement onze mille deux cents
personnes qui souffrent de ce cancer
mais ça veut dire qu'il ya 11200 qui
sont dans des poursuites en justice
or les deux premières poursuites celle
de dwayne johnson qu'on a vu à l'écran
qui est un employé municipal qui a qui
souffre d'un cancer à un stade très
avancé
son procès a été gagnée il avait lu une
somme colossale qui a été ramenée suite
à des interventions de santo a autour de
80 millions de dollars et il ya un autre
cas qui vient de se passer la semaine
il ya deux semaines à peu près monsieur
hardman qui a été compensé à hauteur de
80 millions de dollars là aussi un
cancer dans noces kenya mais ce qui est
intéressant dans son cas c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qui utilisait sa dans son
jardin donc en
des cas de figure différent ici et puis
il ya des méta analyse ce qui met en
évidence que c'est 40 % plus de risques
pour les gens exposés au roundup d'avoir
un cancer note ligne aile ce qui n'est
pas innocent et dernier élément en
france par exemple où il ya des maladies
professionnelles liées à l'agriculture
qui sont reconnues il y en a deux
il y a le concernant le check-in hier et
il ya le parc sera donc ça ne veut pas
dire que tous les cas par cas nous tous
les quatre ans erna match qui m'y a
souligné à ce pesticide en particulier
mais ça veut dire que on commence à
avoir suffisamment d'éléments pour
prendre les choses au sérieux dans ce
dossier là d'autant plus je vous dirais
que ça a été aussi breveté il ya un an
92 comme antibiotiques et qu' il ya une
foultitude études il y en avait déjà
plus d'une centaine l'an dernier ça se
multiplient actuellement sur les risques
pour le microbiote intestinal et
certaines études chez les animaux laisse
croire que c'est un problème sérieux
donc quand on en trouve partout c'est à
dire dans l'eau dans les aliments que
presque tous les tests qui ont été faits
sur lui rinne de gens qui étaient
volontaires pour donner leurs murs
viennent témoigne que ça contient des du
clip all that bas je pense qu'on a
intérêt à regarder très sérieusement la
question et surtout à remettre en
question la décision du canada de
reconduire pour 15 ans d'autant plus que
ce qu'ils nous disent je finis la tuque
ce qu'il me disait ah oui mais les
autres pays c'est ce qu'ils ont fait le
problème c'est que les informations qui
sont sortis notamment dans la foulée des
procès américain met en évidence que il
ya eu des pressions fortes du côté de
les pieds aux etats-unis
et met en évidence que les données de
l'efsa ont été très largement copié
collé sur les données de monsanto et que
leur avis et ses sorties dans la grande
presse européen ans je n'invente rien là
vous pouvez retrouver ça dans le monde
en première page et en 2017 et en 2018
c'est très problématique est en fait ce
qui ressort de tout ça c'est que les
instances publiques actuellement
largement failli à la tâche
si bien qu'on commence à assister à des
interventions justice contre ces
instances là il y en a eu une récemment
au tribunal de lyon qui a été gagné
parce que on avait accepté
alan 16 qui est l'équivalent de l'efsa
blabla pas de l'epson de notre organisme
de de l'arsla au canada basse ils ont
pas respecté le principe de précaution
ils ont été condamnés récemment donc on
voit que le canada non seulement n'est
pas exemplaire il ya déjà quarante six
substances toxiques qui sont interdites
à peu près partout ailleurs et qui sont
toujours acceptés au canada mais ce qui
est extrêmement inquiétant c'est que le
canada s'apprête à alléger ces
procédures actuellement donc et que en
2010 9 en janvier 2019
il y avait eu huit avis d'opposition qui
demande est essentiellement d'avoir un
comité indépendant pour réexaminer tous
dossiers à la lumière de l'ensemble des
informations qu'on aimerait désormais or
non seulement ils ne l'ont pas fait mais
d'une certaine façon en dépit de toute
l'information combat et je terminerai
sur ce petit segment la lecture c'est
qu'on sait maintenant pourquoi les
instances réglementaires arrive à des
conclusions complètement différentes
voire opposées à celles de du cirque du
centre international de recherche sur le
cancer c'est que le centre international
se fie uniquement sur la
littérature indépendant or dans le cas
des organismes de dévaluation il suffit
à 99%
ça ne suffit pas totalement aux
évaluations de l'industrie et dans 99 %
c'est une évaluation négative alors que
dans la littérature indépendante on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya des problèmes dans
peu près 70 % de la littérature
donc on arrive à des conditions
complètement différentes et c'est
important que le public comprenne ou peu
c'est pas des débats d'experts tout ça
tout ça maintenant commence à être mis
en évidence et on est dans un cas de
figure qui rassemble beaucoup au dossier
de la subéraie la volonté de la part de
la grande industrie de retarder toute
prise de décision parce que dans la
pratique faire du fric est donc possible
paloma puis ensuite raymond oui j'avais
une question concernant justement les
aliments ont parlé au début de
l'émission des pourcentages aliments au
canada qui ont une certaine présence de
singly soft lift au 7 mai présent dans
l'aliment comme tel mais est ce qu'il ya
des quels sont les risques pour la santé
des gens mon enfance j'ai vu dans les
derniers dans la dernière
études qu'il y avait une grande quantité
de glyphosate par exemple dans des
aliments comme lui humus mon enfant en
consomment énormément que je me demande
si je devrais lui et lui interdire de
manger des lui mu
donc c'est vraiment au niveau de l'aide
pratico pratique qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire pour se protéger et je pense que
la vraie réponse pour se protéger c'est
vraiment de d'amorcer une véritable
transition de notre agriculture
c'est essentiel ceci dit au plan
quotidien
bon on s'aperçoit que dans le tiers des
céréales pour enfants
il y a des airs les uns des herbiers de
base de glyphosate
il ya dans près de la moitié des
légumineuses
or on nous dit de manger plus de
légumineuses quand il dit qu'il faut
voir également c'est que les études
qu'on a fait mettre en évidence que on
modifie les normes
au fil des années plus et contaminé plus
on augmente les normes
donc est ce que le prévenu est aussi
dangereux
c'est pas des dangers à court terme et
il est évident que par rapport au poids
global de l'enfant
je serais plus prudente avec les enfants
qu'avec les adultes
je pense qu'il est intéressant de varier
au maximum l'alimentation et quand on le
peut il ya un certain nombre de produits
bio qui maintenant sont vraiment à peu
près au prix du marché
ça vaut la peine de regarder cela aussi
mais ça vaut la peine d'amorcer un
véritable débat pour faire en sorte que
les agriculteurs puissent être soutenu
dans une transition parce qu'on leur dit
depuis 50 ans vous alors nous faut aller
et là on peut pas faire un virage à 90
degrés il faut soutenir une transition
réelle vraiment une transition réelle au
niveau de l'agriculture soit
mais j'ai l'impression que tout ce que
vous avez décrit la s'inscrit exactement
dans la même façon dans la même façon
que mon dirais-je l'histoire de la vache
folle les cigarettes dont vous avez
parlé la négation même de delà du
réchauffement climatique donc c'est un
choix sociétal qui se doit d'être fait
et quand on pense ou fait qu'un monsanto
par exemple pour ne pas le nommer est
une boîte de développement majeur au
niveau de certaines régions il ya là un
immense débat qui doit s'inscrire
oui mais le débat est en train de se
faire au niveau des actionnaires je vous
dirais parce que monsanto a été rachetée
par bayer il ya un peu plus d'un an et
demi à raison de 2 63 milliards de
dollars
la mémoire est bonne mais maintenant
bayer ne voudrait plus autour de 52 et
53 milliards
donc ça coûte une fortune à bayer non
pas les procès comme tel mais le fait
que ça ternit considérablement sa
réputation parce que ce qui a pu être
publié lors damon semble dopée père
c'est la volonté délibérée de monsanto
de terre la dangerosité des produits et
de tout faire pour faire en sorte que on
paie des scientifiques pour signer des
articles qui étaient très largement
élaboré par monsanto de façon à
sous-estimer la dangerosité du produit
voire à la nuit donc les mêmes
saint-aubin peur c'est accessible au
public
on peut aller voir sur le site you drive
to know c'est un site américain fait par
une journaliste qui était un rupteur
antérieurement
c'est absolument hallucinant on tombe à
la renverse quand on regarde ça dans le
détail et je pense qu'il est important
de prendre
connaissance de tout cela mais vous
savez si on a cela c'est aussi que les
pouvoirs publics en abandonner en partie
leurs prérogatives on le voit au québec
par exemple actuellement avec ce dossier
des centres de recherche largement payés
par le gouvernement mais gérée par des
gens de l'industrie
je pense que c'est c'est un peu
problématique est là le commun des
mortels se dit non mais qu'est ce que
c'est cette histoire là comment on a pu
retirer les gens qui font partie du
gouvernement ils font même plus partie
du conseil d'administration
donc là on sent qu'il ya une prise de
conscience mais il faut que cette prise
de conscience là se fasse au niveau
fédéral ou si une dernière question
oui enfin vous parliez de l'indépendance
des recherches qui ont été faites mais
comment on peut être sûr que les
recherches sont indépendantes comment
les gouvernements peuvent aller
justement soutirait celles qui n'ont pas
été payés par les jeunes et ce toutes
faites par des scientifiques qui n'ont
pas été payés par monsanto et là vous
avez là une question tu te fait
intéressant l'essentiel des études qui
sont examinés sont des études qui ont
été faites par l'industrie pour obtenir
l'homologation de leurs produits
donc ces études là ce sont des études
venant de l'industrie
ceci dit il y à quelques études qui ont
été faites par des chercheurs financée
directement ou indirectement par des
firmes et là on commence à exiger d'une
part des déclarations formelles de la
part de ces scientifiques
comme quoi ils n'ont pas été rémunérés
par l'industrie il peut toujours y avoir
des façons de contourner cela mais dans
la réalité des choses
on se rend compte que par exemple même
la réévaluation qui est partiel très
partielle qui a été fait par santé
canada s'est appuyé sur des études
publiée dans une revue ou maintenant
plusieurs de ses auteurs ont dit après
coup avoué qu'ils avaient
il ya avec l'industrie voilà c'est comme
c'est comme l'industrie du sucre c'est à
peu près le même il ya quatre ans ou
trois ans il ya des rapports qui sortait
qui disaient qu'ils avaient annoncé être
poussé le produit un demande du canada
une société incroyable geste en
contenant je vais l'amener là où on
dispose les produits dangereux
c'est assez clair que ma décision est
prise mais je n'ai pas ouvert en janvier
nous touchent et j'ai dit je t'aime ma
bien mal à l'aise avec ma décision
et puis surtout avec la lumière de ce
qui a été discuté depuis deux mois
environ pilat et de cette émission ses
classes avec des éclairs oui depuis
mais vous savez en même temps bon je
fais comprendre si on a de l'herbe à
puce par exemple sur son terrain sap le
cadre de vie efficace mais vraiment il
faut réduire au maximum voire éviter de
l'utiliser et si c'est juste parce qu'il
ya des herbes folles
vous savez ce qu'on appelle des
mauvaises herbes c'est une construction
de l'esprit ici très souvent parce que
on sera encore maintenant dans
l'agriculture biologique et il s'agit
qui est une grande diversité un de
plainte
et puis quand vraiment c'est trop
problématique simplement je veux je veux
juste prendre une hutte de votre temps
je prends un risque là j'utilisais ce
produit pour enlever de l'herbe sur un
chemin de campagne au milieu ça faisait
un peu vieillot un peu bon et puis
décadent comme chemin et puis le long de
petits trottoirs également à les y
pousser de l'herbe le long des dalles
j'essayais le vinaigre le sel
combinaison des deux me disant c'est
presque environnementale ça n'a pas
fonctionné du tout est ce qu'il ya un
désherbant quelque chose qui existe sur
le marché
ça s'appelle une bêche j'ai déjà fait
j'ai aussi bêcher sur le sur la route
pour essayer d'enlever les armes
est-ce quelque chose et écoutez moi je
vous répondrai
de façon différente on a éliminé lille 2
44% des oiseaux des champs au canada
depuis 40 ans ce n'est pas seulement à
cause des herbicides
c'est aussi à cause des grandes
monocultures intensives qui font en
sorte qu' on a plus d espace pour que
les les oiseaux puissent se reproduire
on a éliminé à peu près tous les arbres
dans les champs que bon et pts et donner
une chance aux oiseaux surtout que je
les aime les oiseaux écoutez professeur
merci beaucoup d'être venu aujourd'hui
vous allez nous permettre de suivre ce
dossier avec plus de bugs de
compréhension voilà on va regarder des
choses oui il ya une commission
parlementaire qui s'ouvre au québec 1
logiquement il devrait l'annoncer d'ici
deux ou trois semaines et ça devrait se
passer peut-être un tout l'armée est
logiquement à l'automne prochain
important merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation merci beaucoup
alors c'était professeur louise vandelac
à l'institut des sciences de
l'environnement université du québec à
montréal
je sais pas quelle chanson là mais on
est emballé la crème des gens au niveau
d'adaptation
c'était peut-être un peu professoral
parler aux étudiants comme juin
alors qu'aux tests maintenant
alors c'est le deuxième tour de la
grosse boule et puis palma
on va afficher vous allez lire cette
question qui est le fruit de notre
science aujourd'hui on continue à étaler
notre science un peu comme sur la
confection sur une touche alors voici
lequel de ces termes de quoi qu'est ce
que s'est dit n'est pas synonyme
d'herbicides dans à des serbes 1-2 amand
b débroussaillant c'est des fanas des
aucune de ces réponses
c'est pas facile à jouer lequel de ces
termes n'est pas un synonyme
d'herbicides
moi je voudrais pendant toute cette
belle édition vous écouter des
broussailles 1-1 débroussaillant salaire
expliqué b quoi ça nous change des
bouchons rien non ok ces jeunes aux
paysans prendre alors vraiment aucune de
ces réponses
aucun de ces éléments rsa c'est vrai
comment ça vous là comme je sais les
xsara vous lisiez la question avant de
répondre c'est aux décideurs exactement
alors pour faire le tour qui sait qu'il
ya encore des bulls
etc onglet points et moi j'ai des points
vous avez des boules des 50 points
accor est vraiment 5 1.80 d'accord 80 la
première fois la deuxième dont 84 oui
faudrait pas penser que c'est facile
pourtant cette question on va fouiller
dans les archives puisque évidemment on
a entendu la professeure mais il ya
d'autres points de vue il ya d'autres
spécialistes
il ya aussi grands noms du canada qui a
son propre point de vue dans ce soir on
regarde la vidéo numéro 5 ensemble et ça
vous montre les reportages qui
accompagne la diffusion de cette
émission aujourd'hui sur la page de tan
tan canada bon bien sûr vous retrouver
l'endroit pour écouter l'émission vous
presser sur écoute et ça c'est
l'émission de la semaine arrière
on n'a pas beaucoup changé peut-être une
personne dans moins différent mais vous
avez changé de c'est bien une semaine ça
vous pouvez écouter également et là vous
avez les archives pascal à cinq ou six
cette semaine c'est quand qu'ils
traitent cinq personnes différentes je
pense c'est cinq ou six reportages
différents alors versé tout le monde
s'intéresse à tous les journalistes 606
on s'y sont intéressés j'ai coupé le se
sont hissés chance aussi sans souci
c'est sans souci si un souci rend-il
certaines pièces de théâtre il en avait
besoin
reese re ah bon on va arrêter et promet
la fin de la foule dense assez les
archives et puis je vous propose
maintenant oui nous on prêt le jeu de la
semaine
on n'appelle pas ça comme ça c'est
l'image de la semaine
vous devez deviner quelle est l'image
cette semaine moi j'étais dans le bois
pendant une bonne partie de la semaine
je peux cours entre autres les élections
en alberta élections en alberta non je
réponds par oui ou par non évoqué ce que
c'est le résumé ce n'est pas en amérique
en europe s'est étendu en europe notre
dame de paris
oui notre dame de paris mais encore
oui c'était que danse était inclus dans
ces le pape a béatifié qui sur le parvis
de l'église leur avantage
ça aurait pu être ça mais c'est
peut-être al rai la chaîne humaine qui a
été fait pour sauver les os auraient pu
les grandes orgues qui ont été sauvées
ça aurait pu être ça sert à quelque
chose à faire avec la musique c'est sûr
chantait on regarde la vidéo numéro 36
06 eur voilà on écoutait
l année
l'humain et dans l'est
c
avec
d
on voit là ce faire les images
maintenant on va aller dans notre
dernier jeu de la semaine à non c'est
vrai on points à perdre
non mais oui je n'avais qu'à me louis
troisième jeu 50 boules ou points au
mieux points d'accord la grosse boule
hors des points
on est rendu là s'il admet ok bon alors
c'est qu'un boulot c'était gris bull vu
des besoins
tenez pour un des bons mois il faisait
bon d'accord en moyenne voici la
question qui veut dire maintenant marie
jo en moyenne combien de vieux pneus
sont recyclés dans la confection d'un
seul terrain de gazon ça des fois il m'a
des produits chimiques dans le gazon les
gens veulent pas jouer dessus alors le
jeu vous propose de gagner vos terrains
privés non pour le soccer où le football
par exemple il ya douze mille de ces
terrains aux états unis ce que québec en
recense 225 dans la province et bien sur
les terrains de football j'ai pas le
nombre exact mais ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux en amérique du nord pour
un seul je dirais on n'a pas vu les
réceptions on peut rejouer les options
voilà 5000 et 10000 ses vingt mille moi
je dis à 5005 de vieux pneus pour faire
ces 20 minutes
je suis d'abord dû des terrains comme ça
partout il y aurait pu devenue le parent
a raison c'est donc 5000 10000 20000 un
autre vous ne perdra pas ses 50 points
je suis la personne qui a répondu c'est
est la grande gagnante
paloma nom maudit mag
dieu dit il ya des gens qui se plaignent
que quand il joue sur ce terrain et qui
graduent le droitier il mangeait des
moustiques
j'aime beaucoup ces gens des choses puis
ils sont là tout l'été c'est un petit
peu dérangé en avait 2 qui joue sans
quoi sa sagesse moi mais c'est toujours
un bon côté mais même mais elle ça
m'impressionne c'est renversant c'est
vraiment ça c'est pas des gros camions
s'est bien produit si ces bons plats
santé
voilà je sais pas comment ils vivent
chargement c'est la base qui est un plus
ok mais un sou du 2d des trucs verts
c'est c'est comme la basse après ils
mettent des trucs barre en place et qui
doit être résister aussi gmail on voit
espérer situe place c'est qu'il joue
ben écoute et merci pour la science
c'était une très belle émission des
choses plus importantes on a joué
pendant un an je viens m'amuser
merci beaucoup raymond des marteaux
joyeuses pâques à vous également
j'ose pas vous le dire mais est ce qu'on
dit pas aujourd'hui où on fait attention
on change royal appelle l'attention fut
joyeuse fête de famille ou fait des nids
au repos bon d'accord moi je sais le nom
journée de travail hors joyeuse soit 3,1
de tous 50 points
on ne fait bravo vous on n'a plus du
tout et puis on remercie à la technique
pier dutil
maxime l'abri et marc andré deschamps
pour leur soutien aujourd'hui à la
semaine prochaine
et